so we're going to start the afternoon
session so it's my pleasure to introduce
he's coming more from let's say the
integer programming optimization
community and he's going to tell us
about short simplex paths and modest
bottoms thank you so much for to the
organizers for the invitation I'm really
happy to be here so yes I'm going to
talk about some simplex algorithm
lattice polytopes and so let me tell you
what I exactly mean with the lattice
party well of course I mean a polytope
with all integral vertices but in this
talk I'm always gonna focus on polytopes
containing a box in a box which has the
same size in each dimension so it's
exactly zero K to the N and throughout
the talk I will always use n for the
dimension of the space where we live and
K for the size of this box of course
integer I mean that is polytopes appear
throughout several fields in polyhedral
combinatorics I think about the the
convex hull of any set of characteristic
vectors of the ground set these are all
0 1 polytopes in integer programming the
convex hull of the integer point in
rational and also in fractional
relaxation Z of comunitario optimization
problem we have a poly tops which are
equivalent essentially think about the
fractional matching polytope for example
that is that poly tope which is
fractional containing the 0 1 cuba but
the vertices are 0 1 f1 so up to scaling
we can transform it with k equal to 2
good so there's been a very interesting
stream of research regarding the
diameter of lattice polytope so we
started with Madoff in 1989 who gave an
upper bound of n for the case k equal to
1 and this is a yes oh yeah sorry I'm
talking about the combinatorial diameter
so which is
longest path along the edges of the
polytopes between any two vertices the
first result then that I'm aware of is
the upper bound of n given by the DEF in
the case k equal to 1 which is
especially nice cause it tight
for example even the hypercube already
changed that then a few years later
transmitted and Donna extended this
result to a general lattice polytopes
giving an upper bound of K times n then
some years ago we obtained this improved
upper bound for the case K greater than
or equal to 2 and this upper bound is a
tight for k equal to 2 in any dimension
and few years later in 2018 design
purine gave a better bound for K greater
than or equal to 3 in any case I mean
not that this improvement on the upper
bound K and by Kleinschmidt and on still
are essentially linear in K and n so
what about lower bound so worst case the
diameters over lattice polytopes
as I already mentioned some of the
previous results were tight therefore
here I have an N for k equal to 1 and
the 3 halves and for k equal to 2 then
for think about this result for a fixed
K here it is telling us that for any
fixed K 4 and large enough we have that
the lower bound that worst case the
diameter can grow essentially linearly
with n and what about these other two
results instead from what we're
interested in they somewhat talk about
the opposite direction so fix n n then
how do this lower bound grow well for n
equal to 2 below game barony show that
this loss this worst case diameter grows
as K to the 2/3 as K goes to infinity
and similarly for n fixed the sopranos
okagawa shoulder that it grows
essentially like a K to the N over n
plus one so almost linear in K so a lot
of interesting results and there's still
much to do regarding the diameter of
lattice polytopes but the takeaway from
these two slides that that I care about
in this talk is that essentially both
lower and upper bounds are linear in K
and n okay and so that's very important
to me and also what is very important is
that all these bounds are in terms of
these two parameters which are N and K
which somewhat tells us that they are a
good choice when you want to study the
diameter of lattice polytopes as opposed
to the general case of polyhedra or
polytopes
where you normally look at N and M which
is the number of inequalities
essentially all these results don't care
at all about the number of inequalities
good so we're not going to be talking
about diameter we're gonna be talking
about linear programming so what I'm
interested in is this problem so we have
our feasible region is exactly lattice
polytope as we discussed so far and it's
given to us by an external description
of the form ax less than or equal to B
and I'm assuming with our reality that
everything is integral and also I am
given an objective function to be
maximized the over P so what we want to
do is obtain a simplex algorithm that
given any starting vertex arrives to of
course an optimal verdict vertex X star
and being it a simplex algorithm is
gonna trace exactly path along the edges
of the polytope and the question is can
we design such an algorithm that traces
a path which is not too far from the
diameter essentially so possibly our
target would be that we are polynomially
far from the worst-case diameter and we
just saw that this diameter grows
essentially linearly in and in K so what
we want as our first target is a simplex
path length which is polynomial in N and
K alone in particularly independent on
on all the data
and independent on the number of
inequalities so let me just take a
second to also give a little bit of an
insight on how the proofs are different
when you talk about diameter and when
you talk about instead a simplex
algorithm
well of course well this is this is of
course an algorithmic proof so it's very
different you need to give an algorithm
but in general even more importantly
think that when you look at the diameter
you pick two any two vertices of your
polyhedron of your polytope and you if
you want to give a constructive proof
fuku construct such a path using the
information of both vertices here
instead it's very different because you
have only one given vertex your initial
vertex and you don't know what the
optimal one will be so it's much more
difficult because you have to construct
this path only starting from one side
the optimal point good so there are many
interesting result in the literature
that talk about short simplex paths in
lattice polytopes and most of them are
for very specific lattice polytopes
corresponding to combinatorial
optimization problem but what the result
I really want to talk about here is a
recent result by Kitahara Matua means
uno
that is a very general and also can be
used in our setting so what they do I
mean if the result is a bit different
but it stated for our purposes here so
they take a lattice poly tope like ours
but in standard form so that's the main
difference actually the only difference
and they show that they can construct
that actually the Danzig original a
simplex rule gives a path whose length
is this guy over here well so I'm not
really we don't really need to fully
understand this I mean it's a function
of n m number of inequalities K and
that's it but what is interesting is
that we can use it in our setting so
pick our general form lattice polytope
just add our slack variables in this way
we still obtain a lattice polytope
that's great
we still obtain so and the new polytop
is the same adjacency structure to the
original one so great for poor for our
purposes but what changes so is the size
of the box because now we have to take
into account how large these locks can
be so the box is inflated because it can
become as large as s whereas is this max
of the slocks essentially and so in any
case if we apply these results we obtain
a simplex path length bounded by this
number over here and you see we're
somewhat close to what we want it's a
function it's a polynomial in n K but it
just so happens that we have this s that
we want to get rid of okay so that's
what we in this case when I get rid of
and we will see that we managed to this
but through a completely different
approach good so this brings me
immediately to the first results that we
have and I will tell you more later but
I just want to give the results were
able to give a simplex algorithm that
reaches a simplex path length of n to
the fourth K log and K which therefore
is good because it's polynomially far
from our target essentially and K and in
particularly I stress again that it's
independent on the cost vector C on the
description of P and the number of
inequalities so the next question that
we had is well in fact most lattice
polytopes that for which I know we have
a explicit description from
combinatorial optimization problems are
defined by a zero plus one minus plus
minus one constraint matrices so
essentially if you look through scribers
communitary optimization books all the
combinatorial polytopes were aware of
and we have a full description have
coefficients in 0 plus minus 1 so I
thought well can we improve this bound
for such polytopes them and in fact yes
we are able to do that and we do it a
little bit more generally by introducing
a parameter alpha that is exactly the
large
absolute value of any entry in the
constraint matrix defining the polytope
so in this setting we're able to replace
n to the fourth that we had here with n
square and the price we have to play
pays to have an alpha appear inside
inside a log and and this I mean is not
it such a big price to pay I think
because if you think about it if alpha
is any polynomial in n NK then
essentially alpha disappears from that
length and if we get back to my
motivation which was k equal to 1 so for
combinatorial 0 1 polytopes then we
reach just a simplex path of this
Lantern and square log and yes yes you
can I think you would get ya a larger I
think if you you mean if you just
substitute the general alpha do you get
like because I'm just wondering why you
wouldn't do that because you have an N
to the fourth if you do that as far as
pi didn't make any mistake you would
obtain more than n to the fourth year
like n to the 5 or n to the 6 yeah with
facet complexity good so how does it
work so all the I greens I'm going to be
talking about are based on this Oracle
like the simplest Oracle you can think
of in the settings which allows us to
forget about the generous in or the
generous e which often play a kind of a
role in this type of results so I'm just
gonna call this Oracle a bunch of times
so we're given a poly so it takes input
a polytope an objective vector and the
current vertex of P and it either
gives me an output a batterer adjacent
vertex which will serve as the next step
in my path or it just tells me that my
vertex is actually optimal for the
problem
and this can be I mean if you were I'm
not really gonna talk about the runtime
but this can be done in poly time in the
size of the constraint matrix not that
essentially all our greens are based on
this Oracle which also breaks
arbitrarily ties right think about it we
don't really have a specific pivoting
rule that picks an adjacent vertex over
another one is a specific way everything
is gonna work for this very general
Oracle so that's my to-do list that's
what I'm gonna talk about first I'm
gonna give you a trivial algorithm a
what you would just try for directly by
using the Oracle in the most
straightforward way and we will obtain a
length of K and infinity norm of C then
we see that with a bit scaling approach
we can reduce the dependency on C to the
log and then using a pre-processing step
we can completely get rid of the log so
completely get rid of C and so that's
how we obtain the first result and then
later on we're gonna instead describe
much more involved iterative algorithm
which is the one that brings alpha into
the picture so let's see the basic
algorithm so what everything it does so
what's the input our lattice polytope
objective vector and any current given
vertex and it we have to return an
optimal vertex of P and so what do we do
we just iteratively called the Oracle
over and over again with the same
polytop of course our poly tope the same
objective function and we only update
the vertex and that we give in input
because it's gonna be the output of the
previous iteration so really the most
simple thing you can do and in this case
you can easily see and we all know this
is that the length that we obtain is
upper bounded by C transpose X star
minus x0 because everything is integer
right integer and X star and X 0 are
integer and so essentially we're just
looking at the number of level sets
containing integer points between the
two points like in this case two in this
case it's five maybe and if you want of
course a bound that doesn't depend on
the two vertices then you just have K
and infinity-norm oh great so let's see
if we can do something a little bit
better than that
so our first improvement is our scaling
algorithm and so we're gonna use a bit
scaling technique these techniques are
not new they are the first time I think
I've seen them are in papers in the
seventies and have been applied many
many times to solve to give polynomial
time algorithm especially to comunitaria
optimization problems so what we're
doing here is we construct a bunch so
log approximations of our vector C so
better and better approximations each
approximation as infinity-norm
at most two to the team so here's an
example the that's my target vector zero
will have at muster one in the entries
and that's the best we can do that's the
definition c1 then we're allowed to have
also tools than threes and fours until
we are able to have until eight which we
means that week we can write exactly C
so essentially yes it's the best always
so every CI is the best approximation of
see with the such constraint pretty much
good so how are we gonna use this
scaling technique well we're gonna call
now our basic algorithm recursively with
the same polytope that never changes but
now at every iteration we give a better
approximation of the target vector and
the vertex that we give is the one
obtained in the previous iteration so
for example here let's say this is my X
zero that's my X started I don't know
and these are my level sides so
well intuitively you see the level sets
are many from here to X star but in the
first approximation my C 0 is just 1 1
the level sets are few because it's a
rough approximation and so what I do in
the scaling algorithm I go from x0 to
the best point for this objective
function which is x1 now from x1 I
update my objective and they use 1 2 is
the next best approximation and it just
so happens that I'm still optimal
I'm already optimal at x1 which is
therefore equal to x2 and then finally
from here I use my next approximation
which equals my C and which brings me to
the true optimum so here the key step of
course is in using the vertex in input
from the previous iteration because this
exactly allows us to show that now the
length is bounded by K and a log of the
Infinity ok so now the next step was to
completely get rid on C because
essentially what you show is that at the
previous iteration since you were
optimizing a similar function you
covered most of the the space yeah well
from from x0 to that point and so it's
really it's a simple algebraic
derivation yeah I can show you so how do
we get rid of C well we're gonna use a
pre-processing algorithm so the idea
here is the following I'm gonna just
replace in my scaling algorithm my
original objective function with the
shorter one well of course we know it's
easy to see that there always exists the
shorter one the question is how to
derive it in a poly time and here we're
gonna use out of the box that is
altering that due to Franken Tardos in
1987 which relies on simultaneous
I green by Langston and still awash so
that's what it does
piqued our input yeah it has an input
factor in general it can just be a
rational vector for us it will be
integer and it has a positive integer n
in input which somewhat controls the
size of the output the output is a
shorter vector which for us will be
equivalent to C for our purposes with
the right choice of capital n so we have
this brief C integral such that first
it's short whatever this number is
depends of course on capital N and more
importantly well as importantly the sine
of C transpose D is equal to the sine of
brief C transpose e for every integral G
of 1 Norma bounded by n so how are we
gonna use that what we're gonna use that
with a capital N equals K n plus 1 and
so in this way we can immediately see
that X star is optimal for C brief if
and only if really to optimal for see
why well you just need to look at Z so
our Z here is essentially X star minus X
for every feasible point X so X star is
the optimum so it's integer X is any
integer point in our box or in P or any
vertex of P whatever and so of course
since we both are in the box there one
norm is bounded by K n so we can
directly apply these results and decide
so essentially X star so the sign of
this guy is equal to the sign of this
guy
so X star is optimal for one objective
if and only if it's optimal for the
other object
great so at this point you just have to
merge together these two algorithm I
previous Kaling algorithm with this
processing step at the beginning and
then called the scaling algorithm and
you directly obtain this upper bound on
the length so we're done with our first
result what about the second the second
is a bit more involved we want to now
use alpha right alpha which was defined
as the largest absolute values of the
entries in my constraint matrix the
trick here is the following
at every so we're gonna have an
iterative algorithm which at every
iteration will identify one new
constraint of the system defining P
which is optimal at sorry which is
satisfied at equality by every optimal
solution to of my problem so in this way
at every iteration I can decrease the
dimension of my problem by one
essentially these types of algorithms
are nothing new I mean there are several
types of algorithms for different
especially combinatorial optimization
problems that do something like this the
question is can you is one of the first
ideas that come to your mind and for us
it works also I mean one of the reason
why it's a very natural idea is that
every face of a lattice polytope is a
lattice pollito in the same box and for
example a very good description of an
arguing that that's something similar it
is given by Tardos inner algorithm for
communitarian problems you know that
most of these islands are not simplex
like right in our case we want to assume
looks like a great man so we want to
construct such a simplex path good so
here's our algorithm okay let's walk
through it step by step input and output
are always the same we saw them already
here in our initialization step zero we
have a set e that simply is the set of
inequalities that are set to equality
at that specific iteration so these are
the inequalities that if you send them
to equality you identify the face that
you're working on on the specific
iteration and X star just means as well
is the current vertex we are at so what
we do here the first step is we just
project C onto the affine hull of the
face that we're currently working on so
of course then C and C bar optimizing
either of them over the face is the same
so no big deal here it's kind of
technical in a sense why we're apt to do
this next we construct an approximation
of C bar how do we do that we
essentially scale C bar so that it has
infinity norm and cube K alpha and then
round down good now we consider the
following primal problem so in a new
linear programming problem it's
essentially the problem we should be
solving at this iteration so the
feasible region is exactly our
polyhedron with the specific
inequalities of the face at the quality
so this is exactly the face we should be
looking at what different though is that
we're not looking at C or C bar which
would give me exactly the problem I'm
interested in if of course I did the
fixing in a crappy way but it's the
approximation we just had defined and
then we look at the dual now from these
two problems I'm going to derive two
different things from the primer I'm
going to obtain a piece of the simplex
path how I start from my current vertex
X star and they just apply the scaling
algorithm to this guy so I'm gonna
compute a simplex path to its optimum
and this will work nicely for me because
X tilde has control the Infinity norm
okay then what do I use the dual for I
use it to identify what is the next
inequalities to set to equality for the
next iteration good so that's exactly
what we do so
primal I told you for the duel I compute
an optimal solution to the dual that
satisfies a couple of technical
assumptions that I don't want to talk
about right now
in any case then I define the indices
for which Y tilde AI is larger than an K
and of course we have to show there is
at least one and we pick one of it and
add it to our set of inequalities that
we have to set to equality and that's it
and they return back to step one okay so
of course it's very mysterious at this
point we have to prove several things so
first we have to show the vector X star
is optimal indeed then the simplex path
length and finally I'm never talked
again about run time but essentially we
can show that to construct the next
vertex in the simplex path that's how
much work you have to do which
simplifies to this number if you have a
faster description with so anyway in
just the last minute I want to give you
a little bit of the idea of why this
everything works so here's the thing
these are my primer and dwell that I had
in the statement of the algorithm and
the Territorian we focus on a specific
face defined by the set E and we have to
prove that every optimal solution to the
problem lies in F that's the key thing
now let me define C hat as the scaling
of C bar before I took the floor to
define City da okay this two vector are
very similar right because one is just
the floor of the other now if so what I
would really like to look at is and this
problem with the C hat because this is
the true problem I have to solve them
the problem is that now this problem is
no longer the dual to this right there
are no longer a primal to work but
they're almost primal and well right
because C hat is very close to C tilde
so there are nearly primal and
now if they were primarily doer then I
could argue that if in an optimal
solution I have a positive y then I can
set the inequality the corresponding
language of the primal to equality for
every optimal solution that's as
complementary slackness but of course I
can't because they're not primal and
dual however they're almost primal and
dual and this essentially allows us to
show that if the dual variable at
optimality is large enough so larger
than nke then actually you can argue the
same thing about the almost primal and
that's it this is really the main trick
of the proof now at this point
at each iteration we know that the
length of the path this piece of the
path constructed that it is each
duration is is this guy over here okay
you can compute it because of the upper
bound on the length of Z tilde and we
have in total a not an iteration so we
just have to multiply this guy by n and
that's our total length
[Applause]
I have so where did you use the kind of
GLaDOS polytope that you're in a box
that your vertices are in a box to help
you we use it several time yeah actually
several times throughout the proof yeah
I can tell you yeah I think this is a
bit technical so I can tell you a bit
later but it's heavily used
[Applause]